russia has been targeting electricity uh
stations and also dams but it does look
from military perspective as this is
more in retribution and in frustration
at the ukrainian attacks uh success um
for the last couple of days the front
line itself hasn't moved very much if at
all over the last 24 hours if we look at
kharkiv uh initiate first of all the
ukrainian success they have liberated
around an area of land about this half
the size of wales very significant from
a military perspective a tremendous
success but it absolutely does not
portend the end of the war for russia
russia's focus has always been on the
donbass you can see the outline here of
the black that yellow area that's been
liberated is not part of the donbass the
russians were in there but they were
faced with a choice with a very
successful counterattack do they fight
and therefore risk losing soldiers and
potentially getting some of their
soldiers isolated in isiam or was it
better to withdraw the forces in orderly
manner and live to fight another day
they chose the latter the order came
through to withdraw some of the forces
withdrew an orderly manner but some of
them clearly did not as some of the
devastation we've seen on the
battlefield it's not all bad news for
russia though because that was outside
the main area and now the front line for
the russians is shorter makes it easier
to defend the density of russian forces
now because there's a smaller area means
the density of forces is higher and
therefore it makes that makes it easier
for them to consolidate not all bad news
russia would not have liked losing that
land but it's not the end of the fight
if we look now at helsin at the other uh
at the solas more southwest of the the
region let's remind ourselves why
helsing is important it's important
because it's a stepping stone if russia
ever wants to go for odessa it's also
its controls the fresh water down to
russian-held crimea and also because the
nuclear power plant at zapariccia
was isolated from crimea taken off the
electrical grid before
now a very different approach for
ukrainians uh when they deal with helsin
um you can't encircle harrison because
it's on the western side of the denebro
river here uh so and they certainly
don't want to do a full-scale attack
onto an urban environment that could be
very costly so what they're planning to
do is they're doing is they're isolating
the russian forces they're blowing the
bridges across the dunepro river the
russians have been trying to build some
meccano uh bridges using pontoons uh
that the ukrainians continue to
successfully target those basically to
isolate the russian forces the
population of hessena are very resistant
to the russians as well and all of it's
trying to erode the morale of the
russian forces take them away from their
support and force russia into a choice
really as we approach winter do you
leave the forces in hessen and risk them
surrendering or being destroyed or do
you withdraw them from the city and let
them live for another day we will have
to wait and see what what happens on
that front
for us though the key issue here is
timing it's been really interesting
given the winter window which will be
more difficult for fighting to take
place why this is so important for
ukraine two main reasons really the
first one is morale
president zielenski and his people and
his soldiers have been effectively
losing a war for the last six months
their soldiers need to be able to uh
demonstrate that they can take on the
russians on the battlefield with western
weapons and prevail and they've done
that and likewise whilst the people the
ukrainian people have suffered dreadful
privations and invasion forces the
people of uh isiam have now been
liberated and that will send a really
powerful message of hope to the rest of
the country the other reason of course
is the international community president
zelinski is heavily reliant on money and
weapons western weapons to prevail in
this fight if the west believed that
ukraine was a lost cause the challenge
would be
the support would start to dry up
the successes of this operation are very
firmly give ukraine hope and the
international community
hope that president zelinski can prevail
and push out the russians the challenge
of course for the future is what's
russia and president
the president putin's next steps